Kein Mensch verlässt sein Land,
lässt alles zurück, begibt sich auf einen Weg
wie ihn hier Zain schildert, bringt
sein Leben in Gefahr, wenn dieser Mensch keinen
-richtig guten Grund dafür hätte.
-Herzlich willkommen. Ich starte direkt mit
der ersten Frage von 13 Fragen, mit der Konfliktfrage:
Muss die EU mehr Migration
zulassen, um die Krise an den Außengrenzen
zu beenden? Wenn ihr sagt "ja, sie muss
auf jeden Fall mehr Migration
zulassen", dann geht ihr auf's grüne Feld.
Und wenn ihr sagt "nein, das ist
einfach der falsche Weg", dann geht er aufs gelbe
Feld. Okay, alles klar, jetzt wissen
wir, wo ihr steht. Noch immer versuchen
Menschen täglich, die Grenzen zu Europa
zu überwinden, um Schutz zu suchen
oder ein besseres Leben führen zu können.
Dabei ertrinken Tausende von ihnen
im Mittelmeer und die, die überleben,
landen oft in katastrophalen Lagern.
Die Bilder der Zustände an den EU-Außengrenzen
könnten kaum alarmierender
sein und trotzdem fehlen
bis heute gemeinsame Asylsysteme
und Menschenrechtsstandards der Mitgliedsstaaten,
die die Lage verbessern
können. Was muss also jetzt
passieren? Muss die EU mehr Migration zulassen,
um die Krise an den Außengrenzen
zu beenden? Bei 13 Fragen sind sich
meine Gäste erst einmal uneinig.
Umso spannender deswegen: Werden sie sich
am Ende der Folge zusammenraufen
können und einen Kompromiss oder sogar
eine Lösung finden? Ab jetzt gilt es,
wenn ihr der anderen Seite zustimmen wollt,
dann könnt ihr einen Schritt auf sie zugehen.
Und wenn euch vielleicht
irgendwas aufregt, sauer macht,
ärgert, was auch immer und ihr euch das kurz
im Kopf vormerken wollt, dann könnt
ihr schon mal einen Schritt zurückgehen.
Und mein Ziel ist es natürlich, euch
am Ende hier im Kompromissfeld zu vereinen.
Ich lege direkt los mit meiner
zweiten Frage von 13 Fragen, an dich Zain geht
die nämlich: Du bist 2013 aus dem Sudan
über Libyen über das Mittelmeer
nach Deutschland geflohen. Du lebst
jetzt seit 2015 in Deutschland und hast
auch ein Buch über deine Fluchterfahrung
geschrieben. Magst du mal kurz
deine persönliche
Geschichte mit uns teilen?
Vielen Dank. Ich bin 2013 vom Sudan
über Ägypten, Libyen bis nach Deutschland
angekommen, 2015 dann bin ich angekommen.
Ich habe in Libyen 19 Monate gelebt
und ich konnte mir nicht vorstellen,
wie das wirklich ist. In Libyen kann man
einfach Waffen kaufen genauso wie Gemüse.
Und dann die kommen und schießen auf uns.
Also Libyen war kein sicherer Ort, kein
sicherer Platz für uns und für mich selbst
war es gar nichts. Leider ist es traurig,
dass die Leute immer ein falsches Bild
haben von Migranten und Migration.
Dass die Leute, die hergekommen sind,
dass die einfach ihr Leben retten
und die wollen einfach was Gutes machen.
Und ich hoffe und ich wünsche mir,
dass die Leute uns verstehen, warum wir hier
sind. Wenn man in Libyen ist, man
hat nur eine Chance, entweder ertrinken
oder gerettet zu werden, also mit einer einprozentigen
Chance nach Europa
-zu kommen.
-Du sagst also, es gab für dich keinen
Ausweg, du musstest da weg, hast dich
dann auf den Weg nach Europa gemacht. Wie lief
-das ab?
-Nein, das ist noch schlimmer bei mir, das
war noch schlimmer. Wenn ich das erzähle,
ich glaube, das dauert richtig lang.
Also ich habe ganz viele
Gründe, ich konnte nicht nach Sudan wieder
zurückgehen. Ich wollte nur einfach
in einem Land mich sicher fühlen. Dann bin
ich einfach vom Sudan - weil ich ein Student
war und ich war
gegen die Regierung vom Sudan - ich musste
einfach auf jeden Fall vom Sudan weg.
Nachdem ich nach Ägypten gefahren
bin, also gereist bin, habe ich gefühlt,
dass in Ägypten mit einem Anruf
könnte ich wieder in den Sudan zurück gehen,
weil die Regierung in Ägypten mit dem Sudan
zusammenarbeitet. Und dann musste
ich einfach weiter. Aber ich wusste
nicht wohin und wie. Bin ich nach Libyen
gekommen: Jeden Tag ist was Neues
passiert. Jeden Tag wir verlieren Kumpels,
Freunde von uns, die mit uns immer
reden und einfach die Libyer kommen und schießen
auf uns und machen alles, was sie wollen.
Keiner reagiert, keiner berichtet das,
es gibt keine Presse. Es gab
niemanden, der damals in Libyen ist 2013 bis 2014,
als ich da war, berichtet. Jeden Tag
fällt hier eine Bombe oder es wurde jemand
-getötet.
-Man merkt also, wenn du deine Geschichte
erzählt, du bist von einem Unglück
- reicht eigentlich nicht als Wort, aber
ich nenne das jetzt mal Unglück -
ins nächste, von einem Land ins nächste.
Die Leute, die im Mittelmeer sterben,
das sind ganz viele ehrlich gesagt. Ein Tag
bevor ich in diesem Boot mit 651
Menschen nach Italien kam, war ein ganzes Schiff
-mit fast 400 Leuten gestorben.
-Und deswegen bist du dafür, dass die EU
mehr Migration
zulässt. Könnt ihr das verstehen?
Also ich habe sehr, sehr viele
Menschen getroffen, die Geschichten hatten
wie seine und ich glaube, dass wir hier
wahrscheinlich alle der gleichen Meinung
sind, dass das, was derzeit
passiert und was seit einigen Jahren passiert,
inakzeptabel ist. Zum einen ist das Mittelmeer
die tödlichste Grenze der Welt
und das betrifft und sollte jeden
Europäer und jede Europäerin betroffen machen.
Zum anderen ist dieses Thema, die Angst
vor einer angeblichen Massenmigration,
Sprengstoff in den Händen
von Populisten, die damit nicht
nur die Flüchtlingskonvention,
sondern den gesamten Menschenrechtsschutz
und die Rechtsstaatlichkeit in der EU
aushebeln und in die Luft jagen wollen.
Es gilt hier humane Lösungen,
humane Grenzen, Kontrollen und Empathie
zusammenzubringen. Gelingt uns das nicht,
dann verliert Europa hier seine Seele.
Wir müssen verhindern, dass so viele
Menschen ertrinken. Wir hatten 800 Tote
in diesem Jahr im zentralen
Mittelmeer allein. Die Frage ist also: Wie machen
wir das? Das ist die entscheidende
Frage. Wir müssen diese Frage trennen
von der Frage: Wie lösen wir die humanitäre
Krise im Mittelmeer? Wie helfen
wir Flüchtlingen? Und es geht hier um eine Fluchtgeschichte
aus Darfur, aus einem
Gebiet eines Landes in Afrika, wo der Internationale
Strafgerichtshof ermittelt.
Wie helfen wir, dass Menschen wie du
nicht nach Libyen gelockt werden, nicht erst
nach Libyen kommen müssen, nicht in Lybien
versklavt werden und nicht dann russisches
Roulette mit ihrem Leben spielen in diesen Booten?
Also die Frage ist: Was machen
wir? Und ich glaube, wir müssen
trennen. Die Zahl, um die es hier heute geht,
die Zahl von Flüchtlingen, die auf diesem Weg
heute nach Europa kommen, ist sehr,
sehr klein und die Zahl von legalen
Wegen ist noch kleiner. Es gibt keine legalen
Wege dazu. Es gibt
kein Resettlement aus Afrika.
Das wünsche ich mir von Europa, ehrlich
gesagt. Weil ich ich bin auch nicht dafür,
dass die Leute über das Mittelmeer
kommen. Ich habe es gemacht, aber ich würde
niemandem empfehlen, über das Mittelmeer
zu kommen. Aber ich hoffe, und ich wünsche
-mir von Europa, dass die Leute helfen.
-Katja, ich würde gerne zu dir kommen. Du
abeitest seit 30 Jahren ehrenamtlich
in der Geflüchtetenhilfe. Erlebst hautnah
auch wie es ist, wie es den Menschen
ergeht, die es nach Europa, ich sag jetzt
mal, sozusagen geschafft
haben. Was sind denn deine Erfahrungen
-mit der europäischen Flüchtlingspolitik?
-Wenn es darum geht, Menschen mit dem
Notwendigsten zu versorgen,
Lebensmittel, Dach über dem Kopf,
medizinische Grundversorgung, schaffen
wir noch 20 Millionen. Das ist kein Problem.
Diese Leute, die hierherkommen, die haben
alle solche Geschichten. Es kommt keiner
hierher, einfach nur, weil er denkt
"Ach, jetzt gehst du mal nach Deutschland,
da ist es so toll." Die lassen ihre Familien
zurück; die verscherbeln zuhause
das letzte Hab und Gut der Familie,
um irgendwelche Schlepper oder Schleuser
zu bezahlen; bekommen die tollsten
Storys erzählt und kommen dann hier her und sind
erst einmal völlig schockiert. Und wenn ich sehe,
dass ich jetzt noch, ich würde
mal behaupten, 80 Prozent der Flüchtlinge,
die 2015 gekommen sind,
in den Gemeinschaftsunterkünften
sitzen, haben allen abgelehnten Asylantrag,
alle in Widerspruch gegangen, alle von Abschiebung
bedroht. Ich kann gar nicht so
viele Psychologentermine wahrnehmen,
wie ich muss, weil ich jeden Tag Angst habe,
dass mir irgendeiner aus dem Fenster
springt. Also es kann niemals die Lösung
sein, zu sagen, wir nehmen jetzt
alle Flüchtlinge auf. Deutschland ist
ein Sozialstaat und ein Sozialstaat,
der von jedem unterwandert werden kann,
der wird nicht lange Bestand
haben. Ich sehe alle europäischen Länder
in der Verantwortung, aber wir zäumen
das Pferd von hintenrum auf. Die Lösung ist
es nicht, dass wir immer mehr
Menschen hierher holen und wissen eigentlich gar
nichts mit ihnen anzufangen. Die werden
outgesourced in irgendwelche Dörfer,
Käffer, weil da freie Wohnungen sind,
da integrierst du aber die Menschen nicht.
Ich bin ja auch Deutschlehrerin
für Flüchtlinge und ich kann sagen nach 6
Jahren, wenn ich es jetzt mal
prozentual runterbrechen müsste, sind es 70 Prozent,
mit denen ich mich immer noch auf Englisch
oder Arabisch unterhalte. Und ich habe
wirklich einen Draht: Also ich bin
selber Muslimin, mein Lebensgefährte ist
kurdischer Türke, mein ganzes Umfeld
ist multikulturell. Aber es ist echt schwer.
Ich denke einfach, wir sind in der Verantwortung,
aber wir müssen doch mal
-helfen, die Fluchtursachen zu beseitigen.
-Aber dann nochmal zum Verständnis: Du bist
also dafür, dass wir nicht mehr, also
dass die EU nicht mehr Migration zulassen soll?
Also ich bin dafür, dass wir erst
einmal die Leute hier gescheit integrieren
-und in die Mitte der Gesellschaft holen -
-Was brauchen wir dafür konkret?
die 2015, 2016, 2017 - ich meine auch letztes
Jahr waren es ja jetzt wieder über
100.000, wobei es waren über
25.000 Kinder, die hier geboren wurden, über
-die reden wir auch nicht.
-Zain, Maura, ihr habt euch schon
positioniert, ihr seid beide einen
Schritt zurück gegangen sein. Zain, warum?
Weil sie hat gesagt, erst einmal
die Leute, die hierher gekommen sind. Aber
es gibt Leute in Not noch, die sind
noch in Not. Die sind nicht Not, die hier sind.
Ich bin nicht im Not. Ich habe mein eigenes
Auto, ich habe meinen eigenen Job,
-ich habe alles.
-Aber das ist nicht die Masse. Ich kann
nicht so tun, als ob das jetzt
die Masse wäre. Es ist nicht so.
Und genau diese Situation muss
man vergleichen mit der Situation
der Geflüchteten in ihren
Herkunftsländern oder auf der Fluchtroute
oder an den europäischen Außengrenzen.
Und wenn man das mal vergleicht, dann ist
da doch ein Unterschied. Die EU muss
auf jeden Fall mehr Migration zulassen.
Was die aktuelle
Abschottungspolitik Europas bedeutet, ist
dass in diesem Moment Menschen
im Mittelmeer ertrinken, nach Libyen
in Folterlager verschleppt werden oder auf den griechischen
Inseln in Elendslagern
verrotten. Das ist die europäische
Abschottungspolitik. Und dafür gibt
-es keinen Grund.
-Und den Menschen, wissen Sie, wie es denn
geht? Die hab ich da sitzen, die heulen
sich die Augen aus. Die Mutter sitzt
in Syrien, hat Krebs, die können nicht
mal mehr rüber, die Mutter stirbt. Der kann
zur eigenen Beerdigung
nicht, weil sein Asylantrag nicht -
Aber was Sie eigentlich - oder sollen
wir uns duzen oder siezen?
-Duzen, ihr könnt euch gern duzen.
-Aber was du ja eigentlich beschreibst, ist
die diskriminierende und rassistische
Politik, die in Deutschland gemacht wird,
die in Europa gemacht wird, um mit Geflüchteten
umzugehen. Also ich glaube,
die Themen Rassismus und Einwanderung
spielen in meiner Musik
deswegen eine große Rolle, weil ich eine persönliche
Vorgeschichte,
eine Familiengeschichte habe, in der das eine Rolle
spielt. Und weil ich es nicht
ertragen kann, mit anzusehen, wie Menschenrechte
und generell Menschenleben
so mit Füßen getreten werden. Jetzt
zu sagen, wir behandeln die hier schon so
scheiße und können denen nicht
ordentlich helfen, weil wir zu wenig Geld in die Hand
nehmen und zu wenig Personal
schaffen, zu wenig Bildung schaffen, slso müssen
wir die Leute dort verrecken
lassen, wo es ihnen schlecht geht.
Wir schaffen es ja nicht mal die Leute
zu bilden, die schon ewig hier sind. Ich war
vorher 10 Jahre Arbeitsvermittlerin
und habe Menschen in den ersten Arbeitsmarkt
integriert mit Vermittlungshemmnissen.
Nicht mal das haben wir geschafft.
Also ist die Konsequenz,
wenn man hier das Problem nicht -
Und für die Leute, die keine
Sprachkenntnisse haben, ist es ja noch
-schwieriger.
-Aber ist nicht dann das Problem, was du
beschreibst, da sitzen junge
afrikanische Männer, seit Jahren abgelehnt,
ohne Zukunft. Aber das Problem ja
das, in deinem Fall, wir reden von einem
anerkannten Flüchtling und die Syrer
waren anerkannte Flüchtlinge.
Ich habe auch die Abschiebung
bekommen. Ich war auch nicht anerkannt. Ich habe
nur weiter gekämpft, ich habe
weitergemacht. Ich wurde abgelehnt
und fast abgeschoben
während der Ausbildung.
Die Frage ist doch: Haben wir nicht
zwei Probleme, wo wir eigentlich
zusammenkommen? Wir wollen nicht,
dass sich Menschen auf den Weg machen,
die eigentlich in ihren Ländern sicher
wären. Senegalesen sind keine Flüchtlinge,
das wissen wir. Ich war in Senegal,
ich habe mit UNHCR gesprochen. Leute
aus Eritrea sind Flüchtlinge. Für die müssen
wir einen Weg finden, legal
zu kommen oder legal in Nachbarländern
Schutz zu bekommen. Es werden nicht alle
kommen können, aber für andere haben
wir jetzt ein spezielles Problem. Die sind
jetzt hier. Und wenn wir jetzt den Fehler
machen, als Gesellschaft zu sagen,
wir lassen sie in diesen Flüchtlingsheimen,
wir warten,
dass sie irgendwie verschwinden, das werden
die nicht, die werden da bleiben.
-Die leiden da.
-Eigentlich müssten wir ehrlich sein und
sagen, wir machen eine Liberalisierung:
Wir geben denen, die nicht verurteilt
wurden für Straftaten, eine Chance zu bleiben.
Wir müssen Leute davon abhalten,
die keinen Schutz brauchen, sich auf den Weg
zu machen. Aber die, die hier sind,
-müssen wir integrieren.
-Eine Legalisierung, eine Chance zu
-bleiben. Was sagst du dazu, Maura?
-Ich glaube, dass wir auf jeden Fall eine
Legalisierung brauchen. Ich glaube
auch auf jeden Fall, dass wir sichere
Fluchtwege nach Europa brauchen.
Ich glaube, dass kein Weg an Rettung
vorbeiführt. Und ich gebe auch dir
recht, die Situation der Aufnahme in Deutschland
aktuell ist katastrophal und viele
Geflüchtete leiden auch hier darunter.
Das sind die Teile, wo ich zustimme.
Wo ich jeweils nicht zustimme ist,
dass ich glaube, beides ist
eine Schattendebatte, die eigentlich
vom aktuellen Problem ablenkt. Weil wenn wir das in der Konsequenz
weiterdenken
würden, was bedeutet das zu sagen:
"Momentan haben wir schon so viele
Probleme hier?" Alle anderen, die jetzt
an den europäischen Grenzen warten
oder ertrinken oder verrotten, für die haben
wir leider keine Lösung. Die müssen
noch weitere zehn Jahre warten.
Oder Lösungen, die wir gerade gehört haben:
in physischen Folterlagern weiter
ausharren. Das kann ja keine Option sein.
Warum müssen denn Menschen, ihre Familie
verlassen, damit sie sicher leben können?
Es ist doch in unserer
Verantwortung, dort solche Zustände zu schaffen,
dass die Menschen eben nicht mehr
solche Wege auf sich nehmen müssen. Aber es ist
einfach so, es ist nicht
immer damit getan, die Leute zu holen.
Sandra, ich würde dich gern nochmal
fragen, weil du hast ich noch gar nicht
bewegt. Warum, hat dich noch
kein Argument bisher überzeugt?
Da waren sehr viele interessante
Argumente, denen ich auch zustimmen kann,
aber ohne dass jetzt wahnsinnig
viel Bewegung notwendig gewesen wäre.
Ich glaube insgesamt ist es einfach
eine hochkomplexe Frage und es gibt nicht
die eine homogene Antwort darauf.
Die Begrenzung von Migration ist wichtig,
um die Akzeptanz in der Bevölkerung
zu erhalten auf der einen Seite.
Und auf der anderen Seite, um auch den Menschen,
die zu uns kommen,
überhaupt Lebensperspektiven zu bieten.
Und ich finde, das Wichtige ist wirklich,
weil wir haben das in Europa sehr stark
vermischt, Migration und Flucht, Asyl,
das wir das wieder stärker trennen.
Auch für Migranten aus Drittstaaten sichere
Wege schaffen, aber da ganz klar
sagen, hier müssen bestimmte Voraussetzungen
der Arbeitsmarktintegration vorab
erfüllt sein. Während, wenn jemand natürlich
Schutz braucht, dass kein
relevanter Aspekt ist, da können wir nachher
natürlich dran arbeiten, hoffen, dass die Menschen
in den Arbeitsmarkt reinkommen.
Wir dürfen uns aber
natürlich nicht davon abhängig machen.
An der Stelle würde ich gerne
kurz einhaken. Ich finde es fatal, da so
ein menschenrechtliches Ranking
aufzumachen zwischen Migrant_innen,
die es verdient haben zu kommen und andere,
die zurück in den Tod geschickt
werden. Ich glaube, dass diese Unterscheidung
in keiner Hinsicht
gerechtfertigt ist. Die andere Sache
ist, dass erst einmal jeder ganz unabhängig
von dem Fluchtgrund ein Recht hat
zu kommen. Es gibt ein Recht zu kommen
und es gibt ein Recht auf ein faires
individuelles Asylverfahren.
Es gibt kein Recht auf Migration. Es würde
bedeuten, in dem sehr stark moralisierten
Diskurs zu sagen, es muss ein Menschenrecht
auf Migration geben.
Nur letztendlich, wenn wir das in konkrete
Politik übersetzen, funktioniert
das nicht, weil das ja dann
bedeuten würde, es sind unglaubliche Zahlen.
Auch sehr reiche Länder, da können
Sie die Golfstaat mit reinnehmen, da können
Sie China mit reinnehmen. Die hätten
alle dann ein Menschenrecht auf Migration
in die wenigen liberaldemokratisch
verfassten Staaten der Welt. Es würde
nicht funktionieren, das würde uns
ganz klar überlasten. Das heißt wir müssen,
um auch zu gewährleisten, dass die Aufnahmegesellschaften
weiterhin bereit
sind - das ist ja zentral -
weiterhin bereit sind, Menschen aufzunehmen,
ihnen signalisieren können, wir nehmen
wirklich die Menschen auf, die den Schutz
brauchen. Und nicht jeder, der nach Europa
möchte, braucht den Schutz.
Yassin, du bist Musiker und du
sammelst immer wieder auf deinen Konzerten Geld
für die Seenotrettung. Was ist
dein persönlicher Grund dafür? Hast du
da auch eine persönliche
Verbundenheit oder Verpflichtung, die du fühlst,
-zu helfen?
-Ich muss mich schon damit anfreunden, dass
Leute sich auf diese Seite des
Feldes stellen. Ich finde es noch schlimmer,
dass seit jetzt sieben Jahren
ungefähr auf Kosten von Menschenleben, auf Kosten
von Schicksalen, Politik gemacht
wird. Und währenddessen passieren Geschichten
wie seine, die ich unvorstellbar finde.
Also ich kann mich nicht in einen Menschen
hineinversetzen, der sich das alles
anguckt und nichts tun will.
Was denkt ihr denn dazu? Seid ihr grundsätzlich
für mehr Bewegungsfreiheit
und demnach auch Grenzen, die so
offen wie möglich sind? Schreibt es gerne mal
in die Kommentare. Maura, ich hab's
vorhin schon erwähnt, es fehlen bis heute
gemeinsame Asylsysteme und Menschenrechtsstandards
der EU. Warum,
-waren sechs Jahre nicht genug Zeit?
-Ehrlich gesagt, die genau gleiche Frage
stelle ich mir auch - warum? Und deshalb finde
ich es auch fatal, dass wir hier
auf diesem Spielfeld weiter
verhandeln. Das ist im Grunde die Situation,
die wir seit Jahren in der EU
haben, eine sogenannte Verhandlungssituation.
Und da fragt man sich schon, über was wird
hier eigentlich verhandelt? Hier wird über
Menschenrechte und über Menschenleben
verhandelt und die Verantwortung wird sich
immer gegenseitig zugeschoben:
Ohne Italien geht's nicht, deshalb können
wir jetzt nichts machen. Wir müssen
erst mal hier die Situation lösen, davor können
wir auch nicht die Menschen an den Außengrenzen
retten. Und ich glaube,
diese Situation ist unhaltbar. Es muss
jetzt ein Land vorgehen mit anderen.
Es wird in der Vergangenheit, ich finde
das eigentlich einen schönen Begriff,
die "Koalition der Willigen"
genannt. Es kann nicht sein, dass einzelne
rechtsextrem regierte, rassistische
Länder die gesamte Migrationspolitik in der EU
seit Jahren blockieren. Und deshalb brauchen
wir jetzt Länder, Menschen,
Bewegungen, die Verantwortung
übernehmen, glaube ich.
Die Koalition der Willigen,
magst du das mal erklären?
Koalition der Willigen ist die Idee,
dass es nicht mehr alle Mitgliedsstaaten
in der EU gemeinsam entscheiden
müssen, was passiert mit den Geflüchteten
an den Außengrenzen. Sondern dass die Länder,
die durchaus bereit sind
und das ist die Mehrheit, mehr
Geflüchtete, mehr Migrant_innen bei sich
aufzunehmen und auch die Kapazitäten
dafür haben und das mehrfach signalisiert haben.
Es sind in ganz Europa mittlerweile
über 600 Kommunen, allein in Deutschland sind
es über 252, die sagen: Wir haben
hier die Möglichkeiten, wir haben die Plätze,
wir haben den Willen,
die Leute aufzunehmen.
Gerald, Du bist zwei
Schritte auf Maura zugekommen, warum?
Weil genau das die Antwort sein muss
und ich genau wie du überzeugt bin, dafür gebe
es in einigen europäischen Ländern
auch Mehrheiten. Ich hatte viele Gespräche
mit Politikern in den letzten
Wochen. Ich war auch Mitglied
einer Fluchtursachenkommission, die die Bundesregierung
eingerichtet hat. Da waren
eine CSU-Politikerin und eine SPD-Politikerin
die Vorsitzenden
und die hat empfohlen, 40-000
Resettlementplätze, achtmal mehr
als Deutschland jetzt aufnimmt jedes
Jahr, um echten Flüchtlingen, die mit dem UNHCR
oder auch durch Gemeinden, durch
Bürger, durch Städte, wie in Kanada genannt
werden, dass die auf legalem
Weg kommen können.
Also die Frage, warum wir hier stehen,
ist ja: Sollte die EU mehr Migration zulassen
und nicht wie gehen wir mit Geflüchteten
um? Also ich verstehe nicht,
an welchem Punkt du die Differenzierung
schaffen willst, wer Not sucht oder Hilfe
--
-Die Flüchtlingskonvention.
Okay, die gelten jetzt. Aber wir wissen
jetzt schon, dass in den nächsten Jahren
die Ursachen nicht nur Kriege sein werden,
sondern es werden Dürren dazukommen,
es werden Naturkatastrophen
dazukommen. Die Klimakatastrophe wird passieren,
ob wir wollen oder nicht. Und das werden
Fluchtursachen sein. Wo, wenn man hier
mit 250.000 Menschen in einem
Kontinent, wo mehrere 100 Millionen leben, dann kommt
man nicht weit. Und das ist
auch nicht zukunftsgewandt.
Ich schließe mich ja Geralds Vorschlag
an. Aber es war ja eine interessante Frage
drin, die du Yassin aufgeworfen hast,
wenn du sagst, 250.000 ist nicht so viel.
Über so eine Zahl kann man ja
auch sprechen. Aber was wäre denn dann
die Zahl? Also gibt's nicht für dich
irgendwann auch einen Punkt, wo du sagst,
wir haben einen Samariterdilemma?
Also es gibt immer mehr Not auf der Welt,
als der Hilfsbereiteste letztendlich
befriedigen kann. Also wo würdest du denn
sagen, ist dann für dich irgendwo
ein Punkt, wo auch Europa sagen müsste,
jetzt könnten wir nicht weiter
aufnehmen? Darüber müssen wir dann schon auch reden.
Der Punkt ist meiner Meinung nach, wir sind
nicht die Samariter, sondern wir sind
die Urheber des Ganzen. Wir leben auf der privilegierten
Seite der Welt, die dafür
verantwortlich ist, dass die unterprivilegierte
Seite der Welt immer
mehr Probleme bekommt. Und solange das so
ist, solange eine Politik gemacht wird
weltweit, die auf Kosten der Ärmeren,
auf Kosten der Unterprivilegierten geht,
solange wird sich daran auch nichts
ändern. Und dann sind wir in der Pflicht,
wir sind nicht die Samariter, die die Hand
aufhalten, sondern wir sind
in der Pflicht, den Menschen zu helfen,
die vor diesen von uns verschuldeten
Missständen oder mitverschuldeten
Missständen fliehen.
A war das keine Antwort auf meine Frage,
es war eine ganz konkrete Frage,
die um Zahlen ging. Und B ist, die Welt
ist nicht so unterkomplex, dass alles
nur davon bestimmt wird, was wir machen
und das in den Ländern überhaupt kein
Handeln stattfinden würde. Der größte
Teil der Konflikte und der Probleme,
die entstehen, entstehen aufgrund von korrupten
und ausbeuterischen Eliten,
deshalb geht es in vielen Ländern
nicht voran. Das hat eben nicht mehr ursächlich
mit Europa zu tun. Europa könnte
einiges besser machen. Das sehe ich auch so.
Und da sollten wir auch ran. Aber
zu sagen, alles ist nur unsere Schuld,
heißt im Grunde, die sind
überhaupt nicht handlungsfähig, die Leute dort.
-Natürlich sind die handlungsfähig.
-Das sage ich nicht.
Im Umkehrschluss heißt dass das. Aber
ich hätte jetzt trotzdem gerne eine Antwort
auf die Frage: Wo siehst
du denn die Grenze?
-Für mich gibt's keine Grenze.
-Das heißt also 2 Milliarden, 3 Milliarden,
-4 Milliarden.
-Aber wenn die Welt sich so entwickelt,
-dass diese Menschen von dort weg müssen.
-Diese Unterscheidung in sogenannte wahre
Flüchtlinge und nicht wahre
Flüchtlinge, die entspricht nicht der Realität.
Kein Mensch verlässt sein Land, lässt
alles zurück, begibt sich auf einen Weg,
wie ihn hier Zain schildert, bringt
sein Leben in Gefahr, wenn dieser Mensch keinen
richtig guten Grund dafür
hätte. Und deshalb glaube ich,
dass die Flüchtlingskonvention
nicht weit genug greift, nicht mehr alle
Fluchtursachen abdecken kann und wir eine neue
Vision brauchen und die sollte sich
orientieren an dem Menschenrecht
Bewegungsfreiheit.
Katja, du bist einen
Schritt auf sie zugegangen.
Das ist eine These, die ich auch immer
vertrete. Ich kann's nicht mehr hören,
zwischen richtiger Flüchtling und nicht
richtiger Flüchtling und was weiß ich.
Wie sie gesagt hat, da sind wir zu 100
Prozent beieinander. Natürlich sind
die Gründe unterschiedlich, die ein fliehen
vor Krieg, die anderen fliehen
vor Armut. Und ich finde, das ist
auch legitim vor Armut zu fliehen.
Und ich finde das völlig legitim,
wenn diese Leute sich auf den Weg machen
und sagen, sie möchten einfach für sich
und ihre Familie ein besseres Leben.
Das würde ich genauso machen. Das würden
wir, glaube ich, alle genauso machen.
Ich sehe hier eine kleine
Einigung. Ihr seid alle einen Schritt auf Katja
zugegangen. Gerald, muss
Deutschland eine Vorreiterrolle übernehmen?
Ja, ist die kurze Antwort, Die etwas längere
Antwort ist, Deutschland übernimmt
diese Vorreiterrolle seit vielen
Jahren. Zum Glück. Kein Land der Welt hat so viele
Flüchtlinge mit einer positiven
Asylentscheidungen ausgestattet
wie Deutschland. Es ist die größte
Asylbehörde der Welt. Eine Million
Menschen haben hier Schutz bekommen.
In Italien waren 120.000, weil in Italien
die Leute zwar ankommen, aber nicht
geblieben sind. Sie sind weitergezogen.
Also bedeutet das für dich, die Vorreiterrolle
in Deutschland ist schon
-komplett ausgereizt?
-Nein, nein, ich glaube, was wir jetzt
brauchen, ist Deutschland mit Vorschlägen,
die andere überzeugen, ohne die es nicht
geht. Wir müssen die Italiener
überzeugen, um die Seenotrettung wiederherzustellen.
Staatliche Seenotrettung im zentralen
Mittelmeer geht nur mit Italien.
Und wenn Italien seine Häfen
schließt, wenn Matteo Salvini in einem Jahr
Premierminister ist oder in zwei,
dann hat Deutschland ein Problem. Wir müssen
die Italiener überzeugen mit einem
Konzept. Wir retten. Rettung allein genügt
nicht. Wir müssen Leute holen, die Schutz
brauchen. Wir brauchen aber auch Partner.
Wir müssen auch Leute
zurückschicken, die keinen Schutz brauchen.
Da würde mich mal eure Meinung
interessieren. Sollte Deutschland
in der EU-Flüchtlingspolitik eine Vorreiterrolle
übernehmen? Ich habe jetzt
einen Kompromissvorschlag und danach
könnt ihr noch gemeinsam auf jedem Feld
die Köpfe zusammenstecken und euch
einen Kompromissvorschlag überlegen,
den ihr an die andere Seite
richtet. Aber erst einmal fangen wir mit meinem
Kompromissvorschlag an. Da innerhalb der EU
noch kein Konsens über
Menschenrechtsstandards herrscht,
müssen wir auf dem Weg zu einem einheitlichen
europäischen Vorgehen andere Lösungen
finden, die das Leid an den Außengrenzen
schnellstmöglich beenden. Okay, ihr seid
alle einen Schritt auf mich zugegangen.
Dann könnt ihr euch jetzt jeweils in jedem
Feld quasi ein Kompromissvorschlag
-überlegen.
-Ob mehr Migration zugelassen werden soll
-oder nicht.
-Weil die andere Gefahr ist, was ich gehört
-habe, ich habe diesen Vorschlag gemacht.
-Weil es einfach, es gibt kein Vorwärts.
Das war bisher eine ganz schön
hitzige Diskussion. Ich hoffe, dass wir gleich
noch ein paar Kompromisse
finden können. Habt ihr denn noch einen?
30.000, 40.000 im halben
Jahr, das ist nicht viel.
Also es muss mehr Migration
zugelassen werden, sonst werden sich diese Probleme
-nicht lösen.
-Willst du das vorschlagen? Weil ich rede
-eh schon so viel.
-Ok, ja dann schlage ich das vor.
-Grünes Feld, was habt ihr euch überlegt?
-Wir haben heute keinen Kompromiss im
Angebot, weil bei Menschenrechten und beim
Menschenleben darf es keinen Kompromiss
geben. Menschenrechte müssen
unverhandelbar sein und bleiben.
Und das möchten wir an dieser Stelle
gerne signalisieren. Deshalb kein Kompromiss
-von unserer Seite.
-Na gut, man kann natürlich sagen
Menschenrechte sind unverhandelbar,
aber das ist eine religiöse Doktrin. Ich muss
alles in konkrete Politik umsetzen
können. Und da gibt es natürlich auch bei uns
bei den Grundrechten in Deutschland
immer wieder Abwägungsprozesse,
weil es kollidierende Grundrechte
gibt. Und ich habe ein demokratisches Prinzip,
also ich muss natürlich auch im Zuge
der politischen Willensbildung Mehrheiten
organisieren. Es gibt natürlich die Grundrechte,
aber das absolute Grundrecht
dafür, das würde ja bedeuten,
dass jeder auf der Welt ein Recht hat,
nach Deutschland zu kommen, das kann
es nicht geben. Das kann eben
auch in praktische Politik nicht
übersetzt werden. Und das macht es aber so
unglaublich schwierig. Man hat dieses ganz
hohe Menschenrecht, was aber als konkrete
Politik in der Form wie es hier
gedacht wird, mit auf die 10 Milliarden bald
zu gehend eine Menschheit,
niemals umsetzbar ist. Das heißt, wir müssen
-es umsetzbar machen.
-Dann müsste man ja das Menschenrecht
-anpassen.
-Es gibt kein Menschenrecht auf Migration.
-Es gibt gibt's nicht.
-Es gibt ein Menschenrecht auf
-Bewegungsfreiheit.
-Der Ausreise, aber nicht der Einreise. Das
ist der große Unterschied. Im Völkerrecht
gibt's das Recht auf Ausreise aus einem
Staat. Aber nicht, dass ich irgendwo
überhaupt einreisen kann, das gibt es halt
-nicht.
-Und wo sollen diese Menschen dann bleiben?
Und ja, es stimmt, es darf nicht
einfach nur bei Grundsatzpositionen bleiben,
sondern man braucht konkrete
Vorschläge, wie man damit umgehen kann. Und die haben
wir, die liefern wir seit
Jahren. Die einzigen, die blockieren, sind
-nach wie vor die Politik.
-Dann höre ich mir gerne, wir hören uns
-gerne euren Kompromissvorschlag an.
-Ja, wir haben uns jetzt was ganz Konkretes
noch von dem von dir
eingebrachten Kompromissvorschlag überlegt.
Diese Situation, dass man lange diese Unsicherheit
hat und nicht wirklich planen
kann und das deprimierend für die Menschen
ist, diese zu beenden. Und zu sagen,
wer jetzt eben aus diesen Ländern da ist,
zwar kein Asyl zugesprochen bekommen hat
oder keinen Schutzstatus, der darf
aber bleiben. Aber gleichzeitig klar
zu kommunizieren, für alle, die jetzt
neu hinzukommen, gilt das dann nicht mehr.
Nur Verständnisfrage: Das heißt,
nachdem man das jetzt einmal großzügig
samaritermäßig gemacht hat, ist man
danach strikt und verhindert eine Migration
-in die EU?
-Man macht sich vielleicht erst einmal
Gedanken, wie man sie finanziert und wie man
die Leute menschenwürdig unterbringt.
-Und bist dahin verhindert man sie.
-Nein, nicht verhindern.
Nein, wir wollen nicht verhindern. Wir wollen
einfach nur sagen, unser Ziel ist,
klar zu signalisieren, die, die jetzt
da sind, die viele Jahre da sind, die genau
das, was du beschrieben hast, die auch die Akzeptanz
in der Bevölkerung reduzieren,
weil sie sagen "das ist doch kein
Erfolg, die sitzen da rum." Diese jungen Menschen
wollen nicht herumsitzen, die wollen
ihre Familien besuchen, die wollen arbeiten,
die wollen und die werden
bleiben. Realismus. Wir wollen irreguläre,
lebensgefährliche Migration von denen,
die dann in dieser Lage enden, weil sie keinen
Schutz zugesprochen bekommen, die wollen
wir reduzieren. Und dafür wollen
wir Resettlement, legale Wege,
Aufnahme - die wollen wir erhöhen.
Ja, ich finde, es waren
einige interessante Punkte,
wo ich das auch schade fand,
dass wir nicht weitergekommen sind. Aber
ich glaube, dass so vielleicht
der Hauptunterschied ist, dass bei euch
einfach viel mehr ein politischer
Dogmatismus ist, einfach eine klare
Haltung zu etwas. Und dass wir mehr
zum politischen Realismus auch verpflichtet
sind und geschaut
haben, was ist politisch möglich.
Was wir eigentlich schade finden
und was ich schade finde, ist, dass über
dieses Thema und Rassismus
überhaupt nach wie vor verhandelt werden muss
und diskutiert wird. Denn wir glauben
nach wie vor, kein Kompromiss, das ist
die einzig richtige
Lösung bei diesem Thema.
Ich habe sehr viel gelernt. Das war
eine gute Diskussion. Aber ich bin enttäuscht,
dass wir am Ende bei den Themen, wo ja
in der Diskussion noch ein Konsens war,
da ist ja schon einiges da an Kompromiss,
aber der fundamentale Unterschied ist,
wie erreichen wir das? Und da bin
ich überzeugt, wie meine Kollegen
und Kolleginnen, glaube ich: Wir müssen
Menschen überzeugen. Wir müssen Mehrheiten
überzeugen in einigen
EU-Ländern, wie man das erreichen kann, sodass
diese Mehrheiten Regierungen
wählen, die das dann auch tun. So gesehen gibt
es keine Alternative dazu, dafür
zu werben. Und dafür war das eine gute
Diskussion, weil doch am Ende
recht viel Gemeinsamkeiten sichtbar wurden.
Ich wünsche mir vor allem, dass die Menschen,
die jetzt gerade leiden,
die akut leiden, die den Tod
fürchten müssen, nicht instrumentalisiert werden
-für irgendeinen Wahlkampf.
-Ich bitte und ich hoffe, dass die Leute
uns helfen. Ehrlich gesagt.
Das ist meine letzte Hoffnung.
Ich danke euch für die Diskussion.
Damit würde ich sie jetzt hier an dieser Stelle
-beenden.
-Danke, dass wir hier sein konnten.
Falls euch die Folge 13 Fragen zum Nachdenken
angeregt hat, falls sie euch
gefallen hat, lasst gerne einen Like
da. Hier könnt ihr gerne den Kanal abonnieren.
Hier oben findet ihr ein weiteres
Video von 13 Fragen und hier unten ein weiteres
Video zum Thema.